[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to be talking about the wrong door
in practice we have an Aikido so what we
call ron dory and my school is probably
a little different than most people
would call ron dory it has a set of win
criteria for both attackers and the
defender the gays and the nage so I'm
gonna talk a little bit about that today
with both Josh and Mya
so let's get those two in here okay so
we're gonna have Josh and Mya both be
gay and non-gay and we'll run them both
a few times so you can kind of see
what's going on we're gonna use the
infamous pool noodle for it the reason
we use this pool noodle is because the
pool noodle offers us the ability to
train the the defender to hit full steam
so you can hit as hard as he wants and
he won't feel guilty about it you won't
feel bad because the poolroom so it
doesn't actually hurt so we want to
train ourselves to have that ability so
if we were defending ourselves the
weapon and someone's coming at us we
learn how to hit and move it and move it
move it's also good for our defender
because our defender won't take
unnecessary precautions right so while
an intelligent person will likely if I
swing a leg pipe what not to get hit by
the lead pipe a crazy person or a person
who is feeling no pain at that time
might just run at you anyway so we want
to train Josh for a situation where this
person is just coming at them so I'm
gonna explain the basic win criteria so
you see a box we have here this box a
little smaller than the normal box we
use we usually ignore you normally use a
15 by 20 or larger size box but this is
the box we're gonna use today
if Josh goes out of bounds for any
reason while he's the the defender then
he's out so he loses so that's a win
criteria for Maya Josh steps out of the
box in any way okay josh is also gonna
have this pool noodle if the pool noodle
comes out of his hand in any way he also
loses beating he drops it on his own or
she tears it out of his hand that's it
he loses so he loses if he steps out of
the box he loses if he loses the pool
noodle he loses if mine is able to
stagnate him okay so stagnation means
that he's controlled in a way that he
can't really use that weapon right now
he could try to switch the weapon and do
whatever now if he can use the weapon
right so he can hit him with that weapon
then he's not stagnated so if he had
stagnated for around two three seconds
he's just kind of a judgment call it
looks like he's actually stagnated
meaning he can't really use that
and effectively then he's also out or if
any part other than his feet touches the
ground so this hand comes down and
touches the ground or he drops a knee or
definitely his butt hits the ground he's
out so all four of those things will end
it for Josh he goes out of bounds he
loses his weapon he gets stagnated or he
gets knocked on the ground or touches
the ground anyway with anything other
than speed his only win criteria is to
go the entire time so he wants to go the
entire time that we're doing this we're
gonna run these for 10 seconds I'm just
getting counted off right now 10 seconds
roughly you can run a timer if you want
to be real strict do whatever you want
so that's basically and I'm gonna step
out of the box if she stagnates him
knocked him out of the box takes his
weapon or I don't know which one I
didn't say but he those four criteria
then that's gonna be a loss for him okay
so I'll say go he wants to do that Myatt
your job is to try your absolute best to
get Josh and mines a little upset from
weeks recently where people said she
wasn't trying her hardest so she's
really done they'll be gonna give Josh
the hardest time he can have okay ready
go 1 2 3 4 5 7 8 9 10 now man good job
alright last is lost and all alright so
you can see Maya certainly was trying
her hardest there and Josh was trying
his hardest so this isn't a little light
drill it's not a tiny practice this is a
practice where absolutely and certainly
josh is trying his hardest to stay free
and use that weapon and my is trying her
hardest to get him now of course that
will that will change depending on how
athletic and skilled the people are so
we're gonna run this now from the other
side and we're gonna let you see what it
looks like when Maya defends against
Josh and again she's gonna try
absolutely as hard as she can
Josh she's gonna try as hard as he can
if there's a stagnation I touched the
ground I knocked out of bounds or a
weapon loss then that's also gonna
that's gonna that's gonna end it all
right so we're gonna go again ready go
what two out of bounds reset ready go 1
2 3 4 stagnation weapon disarmed all
right good yummy all right so you guys
get the idea when you see someone who's
done it for a long time josh has been
doing this now for about 12 years right
so when you see someone who's done it
for a while it might look like it's a
simple practice but it's not right so
it's a practice that you have to build
up to get skill and when you see if the
difference mines been doing it for a
while now just not nearly as long as
Josh so when you see someone who's
really good at attacking come in you see
how hard the practice actually is so
it's important to understand that when
were going in full-speed then we're
going in full-speed now the severity of
this practice could be increased by
number of attackers you do could we
could use harder weapons we can use
rattan sticks if we want or whatever
people are willing to risk we could have
all kinds of things if we want but this
is a basic idea of the practice you're
doing the good I canna practice if you
can manage to stay up on your feet not
be stagnated not knocked out of balance
knocked out of bounds basically means
you'd be pushed into a wall where they
would trap you against the wall and you
couldn't get out anything keep your
weapons if you can do all those things
Aikido is considering that the success
you're having successful like you know
now it's not true success is true
success is just having
conversation the best thing would be if
Maya came at Josh and Josh just said hey
let's not fight and she said hey you're
right that would be the best Aikido
situation but we're talking about the
physical state then this is what it
looks like right so Josh even though
Maya won't have any of the conversation
Josh is able to keep her a distance and
do that right so this is our basic
rondure practice we use here at this
school
I'm Christopher Hine thanks for watching
[Music]